guys come see me at the west palm beach
improv december 4th and 5th come see me
at the shovel year theater in boston on
december 10th i'm really looking forward
to that it's almost sold out so get
tickets and then also almost sold out my
first time at the borgata in atlantic
city saturday december 11th all tickets
on sale at savilecanocomedy.com
brian quinn will be at the show at the
borgata he just told me that and
there'll be other surprises hope to see
you there my dad will be there too whoa
i wish i could go but i can't because
december 2nd to the 4th i'll be in
phoenix arizona december 17th and 18th
i'll be at west palm beach in florida uh
then december 26th to the 31st sal and i
will be together in texas missouri and
ohio january 29th i'll be out to borgana
february 5th beacon new york city march
25th to win las vegas christy comedy.com
for all the new dates that are up there
thank you man we love
don't be a you don't run away from your
feelings babe don't be afraid don't be
ashamed don't hesitate to say hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey baby
touch the feel of hey babe
the fabric of our lives what's up babe
what's going on baby at all um whale
bone do you wearing the whale bone hat
they keep hitting me up they want me to
do an interview i'm gonna do an
interview a whale bum are you serious
they keep emailing me they keep bumping
up they say hey we just noticed that you
wear the merch whale bone there it is
you wear the whale bone whale bone on
the show
so for serious i swear to god for
serious sex wow yeah wow yeah
all right i just saw a funny meme
speaking of whales i saw a funny meme
yesterday uh it goes um it said the
sperm
uh i'm sorry the blue whale has the
biggest vagina in the world it can fit
eight humans inside of this vagina eight
humans inside of a vagina and i said
making it the second biggest vagina
on planet earth the first being men that
still wear masks outside
so i just
i just laughed at it that's not an
anti-vaxx probably joke we're just doing
a little ha-has but i did not realize
that a whale's vagina is that big can we
confirm that pimpy can you please
confirm actual size of the biggest
vagina on earth on the animal kingdom
who were the eight people who went in
who went in yeah i don't know dude i
mean
that ninth person ninth guy or whatever
they're like eight and he's like oh man
do you think he wanted to go in or you
want he want to be spared you wanna yeah
eight and then the eighth guy popped his
head back out i was like we're done here
we're done yeah there's no this this
this whale pussy's been filled you're on
you're the ninth guy right are you like
god damn it i wanted in that yeah or are
you like yes thank god
well i would say
i'd be happy temporarily happy but my
brain would go immediately to how many
people can the whale fit in its ass
i don't want i don't want to be first up
for that yeah you know you you have to
be you're first in line for the rear
then i'm first in line for the rear i'm
in the rear of the whale um
what do we got pip is the screen not
working i'm just trying to get it back
up okay um pimp how was the salad pin
panda had a grilled chicken salad what
would you put dressing on it what'd you
put i don't do dressing
have you ever met anybody who does that
can you i've done i've done salads
without dressing but it's not a habit so
then you pimp have gone to the point now
where you're genuinely just eating for
nourishment the emotions aren't detached
yeah eating's it's just it's [ __ ]
right eating's [ __ ] when i lost
i go up and down i fluctuate a lot one
time when i one of the times i lost 50
uh that was my attitude i ate for energy
for nourishment that's it i ate from the
energy you have to flip that switch my
favorite part of the day now is the
shower that's the best part of the day
why
it just it feels good i don't know
that's where he sneaks his cookies
wait a second yeah what do you mean in
the shower like you like
like a favorite part of your day like
what was it because you like just
feeling your body naked and wet no it's
just like hot water refreshing hot water
like no one can contact me
right
my favorite part of the day i would say
is at night at night when the kids
finally get put to sleep and i can lay
down and i have about 10 minutes
before i fall asleep and i'll start to
begin a show yeah and pass out within 10
to 12 minutes but that is we're not
laying down in that bed yeah
the promise of a good night's sleep
about to happen about to happen yeah
because then i know i'm going to wake up
in the morning it's all starting i
honestly don't know how you guys do it
whenever i'm around you there's
constantly people calling you or there's
constantly something like you guys it's
crazy
it's terrible well that's why i'm i'm
quitting the podcast that's why i look
that's why i look like this
um
yeah i actually my shower driving
showers and
uh falling asleep is when i think of all
my ideas actually because it's the only
time my head gets clear so that's why i
start meditating again i can only think
of stuff i can only only ideas only ever
come into my head when i'm driving now
isn't that crazy i can't even think
about even attempting to ride a new bit
or come with a new idea i have to be
driving that's why i have to have no
music on yeah that's about that's why i
thought you were going to make fun of me
for like him in the [ __ ] i uh most of
the times when i drive i i drive in
silence you know what i've been
listening to a lot lately or just music
yeah that's or
or silence there's only three things i
listen to in the car it's mostly jazz
and it's mostly jazz from the 40s
but i listen to wbgo 88.3 or 40s on four
shut up so if that's not it i'm
listening to classical
i no words classical could play and i
could still my my mind can still go is
that what you mean yeah so you don't
listen to like you won't pop on some old
school whitney or something and vibe out
on not in the car at all the only other
thing i would do in the car is stern wow
that's it and that's on like traffic i
put turn on in traffic
because it helps really helps but like
other than that silence
i can drive five hours i've done it i do
it all the time i do it all the time i
feel bad for my girlfriend because
like
she's the trooper like but she'll she'll
look on her phone fall asleep and we'll
talk but a lot of times no actually
she's like can i put on something please
go ahead but a lot of times she she
won't she'll just let me have it wow you
guys wouldn't like my car rides it's
loud as it can be rap music yeah yeah in
a chevy malibu yeah you're like you're
like the [ __ ] uh jamie kennedy
that's the movie malibu
yeah shout out jamie kennedy i met him
for the first time the other night shout
out jkjk during the study uh this was a
study about what i watched scream the
other day
yeah i watched it not for the first time
no no but jamie kennedy got it
um during this shout out cotton weary
liv schreiber's uh character who was
accused of killing nev campbell's mother
but he didn't it ended up being skeet
alright a lot of weird names there
that's liv schreiber yeah no it's not
cotton weary is for show
yeah
look it up what yeah he was the one that
was accused
until you found out it was skeet skiing
got it yes yes yes yes yes he was
[ __ ] cotton weary that's right
cottonwood skeet
ulrich is the actor's name now the word
skeet was then co-opted
by i'm assuming the hip-hop community to
mean
semen
so now
skeet who had a whole life
of normalcy
except for the fact that his name was
unique
now goes by in popular culture
his first name being ejaculate that's
what it is yeah now is skeet a nickname
or is it i don't know look him up skeet
skeet all rich no relation no relation
to um
anybody else at the last name all rich
skeed all rich if you click on his wiki
does it say that's his natural born name
now skeetologist has he done a lot of
other things
oh he's in the craft he he's he's been
an actor for
you know he's been working for
since scream you see his real name no
ryan
ryan
oh wow brian trout
yeah brian
well where the hell
did he get his name skeet ulrich from
then
skeet is an interesting interesting
nickname so you think skeetski
i don't know where they got i don't know
why skeet skeet became that little john
yeah i know but i don't know
why it became that steve ultra it's bio
real quick it's i think i said something
that his father kidnapped him altrick's
father kidnapped him and his brother and
he was six years old and they spent the
next three years moving from florida to
new york and then to pennsylvania they
were
reunited with their mother in north
carolina where his father disappeared
from his life the nickname skeet
originated from skeeter a nickname he
was given by his little league coach
because of his small stature and because
he used to come on first base
because he was as fast as a mosquito oh
that's what it is along with his slide
frame he had poor health including
numerous bouts with pneumonia jesus oh
jesus open heart surgery to repair a
defective ventricle at the age of ten
holy smokes my goodness skeet god damn
he's studying marine biology speaking of
marine biology um um
we have a whale's vagina stat
to classical music then back to whale
vagina okay so first let's do this
classical music stat that we have a
happy brain is a healthy brain and
classical music especially that evokes
positive memories can increase dopamine
and neural connectivity in the system
slowing down the aging process so if you
want to not grow old
wow i know have you ever heard that
people play classical music for their
plants and it helps the plants thrive
really that's true for real do you know
that people talk to their plants those
plants
do better than the people than than
plants that don't get spoken jasmine
talks to the plants every jasmine hasn't
talked to me in two months right she
talks to the tulips like all day
everywhere maybe you should undergo some
photosynthesis and maybe you can that's
what it is to your relationship that's
what it is i'm sorry my penis isn't a
toilet
[Laughter]
stronger vibrations have a negative
effect dr uh nasa says the vibrations
improve oh i'm sorry smithsonian and
nasa show that mild vibrations increase
growth in plants while harsher stronger
vibrations have a negative effect the
vibrations improve communication and
photosynthesis which improves growth in
the ability to fight infection
rick ric flair's head i didn't know
plants could get infections what do you
just give a little a little amount of
soap yeah they could get they get
infections plants can get in you ever
see like sometimes uh you know one one
leaf will be like
that's plants that's leafs in fact well
they get like a rot
interesting i think i think yeah because
we have i have i think our plant count
here i'm not joking i think our plank
out here is 60 something plants in this
house 60 plants that you
water all day ever you don't have a
landscaper i don't mind the the lady
does it she she's a plant mother she
loves the plants i love them too i love
having plants around they get out of
oxygen they get a life well you mean you
have a plan i love my lady yes
no no no no no my girl yeah my partner
got it guys okay
do you name them the plans
no i never named them but but i bought
my first one i bought a cactus you
bought a cactus like that i was supposed
to take care of but then she takes care
of it what do you water it once a year a
cactus it's like no but it's like once a
month
something like that but see i would i
would be more nervous because i forget
to water it
yeah it's just i'd rather water can't
over water too that's bad that's worse
you ever see when we have a nat up here
too
like in that when it's bothering us the
podcast these [ __ ] yeah it's because
of the how we have so many plants right
because they just so what are the gnats
come out of the plants i think if you
over water it maybe they do they give
birth to naps not the plant but
a nat will go in there and then maybe
maybe maybe a wine and another and then
a few like nine hours later you got a
bunch of nets you got a couple of
natty's nat city yeah i like natty ices
yeah um
it says you can like drown your plants
over water yeah yeah you drown your
plant just like you can just like you
can drink yourself
with water into a drowning is that crazy
yeah i know i heard that you can drink
too much water you know how many plants
we have that when i go on vacation when
we go away or even for like the like
well not the weekend but we have to get
somebody to come here to water our
plants do you have is that a plant guy
no no we like a friend friend or a
family member wow you have to 60 plants
60. oh my goodness look at that
um
sal i got something to tell you please
you don't have the slightest idea how
mysterious whale vaginas are no i don't
know sal no no you think you know but i
have no idea you don't even know this is
the true story as it turns out when
vaginas stop start being real and stop
being polite and stop being real it's
real world vagina right here that's
right as it turns out a citation vagina
have unusual folds with unknown
functions that differ between species in
order to really get deep into what's
going on here the researchers collected
59 whale [ __ ] reproductive tracts
from 20 species of cannitations that had
washed ashore and died of natural causes
they sliced the parts up gross and
measured and counted the vaginal folds
how many vaginal folds do you think of
whales vaginas i don't know but vaginal
and folds are two words i don't like
together
you know you got to deal with the
vaginal yeah you got to deal with
vaginal folds i have to deal with
vaginal folds on a daily basis because i
have to clean poopoo out of them but it
happens all right and then but the
baby's fine well not an in not a young
vaginal fold no i'm talking about
jasmine
you got me gotcha uh what do we got a
blue whale's vagina what'd you see
pimping i'm no i'm searching for
something on this hold on okay okay yeah
sometimes
goes rogue so what's the male
the male
being whale penis it's got to be if it
could fit eight humans right like what
is that if the biggest if the vagina if
the blue whale has the biggest vagina on
the planet
does the blue whale male have the
biggest penis on them right and what if
you're a blue whale with a small penis
but it's like 10 feet
yeah yeah but you still got a little
dick yeah
yeah i found a gold mine for you chris
here here's your dream here we go 14
bizarre female reproductive systems in
the animal kingdom i bet you can get
them all pregnant let's go let's do it
let me move rick
oh yeah damn it rick sometimes he's
by the way ric flair probably i think
the best mullet even a better mullet
than theo vaughn just so everyone knows
there's a ric flair statue here in sal's
home yeah he's not sitting over there
blocking the television
could you imagine for all 60 episodes we
had rick flair off camera
and we never mentioned it
he had to remain silent until now wait
one of these
if not this one it was probably last
week but i think it was our year yeah we
just skipped right over we blew right by
we didn't even make a we didn't know
that was our 52nd episode yeah no hubbub
at all about it because this week it's
about 49.
the one that went out was 49
right so this is could be the 50 seconds
it might it might be if it would be your
anniversary if it wasn't it was last
week
this is the second episode we made it
one year look at us we did it we're one
we're we're crawling now crawling um
okay so kangaroos and most marsupials
have three vaginas so that's amazing
so so which one does the partner use or
can he use all three can you bang all
three of kangaroos and can she get
pregnant through all three let's find
out females technically have three
vaginas and two uteruses or uteri one is
strictly used for giving birth while the
other two are connected to the uteruses
the adaptation allows animals like
kangaroos to be 24 7 baby making
machines let me but it's got a lot of
pressure on the male kangaroo there your
first time you got to know what which
one to go into right i don't know what
the hell is look if i'm if you give me
you pull out three vaginas
and then you hit a uteri yeah you know
what i'm saying what the hell to do
kangaroo so i was waiting for you your
joke here where the kangaroo must be
puerto rican must be puerto rican there
it is 24 7 baby man and they box so and
they bought it
nice
nice there you go
yep and then and they make a very good
chicken
so so i always got a baby hanging off
him oh he's got a baby hanging off them
yup
and
they hate me
so
the the
the desert grassland whiptail lizard is
an all-female species work it of reptile
that is native to the southwestern
united states and mexico they produce
through a process called
parthone parthogenesis an ability that
allows them to cross their own
chromosomes
to clones of the mother parthenogenesis
so this person this this whiptail lizard
just
impregnates itself and keeps spitting
out clones of itself interesting so how
do we not know that that seems like
something that's very unique so a female
so a whipped tail lizard domino man
don't need no man at all
man
imagine a female like that that just
keeps giving birth automatically to her
own self over and over uh narcissist
that's what i'm saying
um female duck oh sorry it takes two
female whip tails by the way oh wow so
pseudo so the feet no oh now it's the
the thought
the thought flick thickens i said
the plot thickens whip tail lizards
they're lesbians because they it
consists of two females mounting each
other intertwining tails and wriggling
as if copulating right but then which
one gets preg
it's anybody's game maybe both i guess
yeah
yeah maybe they both get pregnant
i don't know female duck vaginas are
specifically shaped to thwart unwanted
shooters so female duck vaginas they you
can't try and get into a female dark
vagina without consent watch what
happens check this out female ducks are
unique because they have vaginas most
birds do not have vaginas or penises
what no single opening known as a cloaca
or a vent responsible for all
reproductive and digested needs so
they're wow
female uh ducks genitals are also
distinctive because of their shape the
shape of a duck's vagina is elongated
and spiraled to deter unwanted well
because luxury male ducks are known for
their sexual aggression and deviance
genital competition has developed
between the two sexes wow so daffy duck
was a little got a little handsome yeah
i got all hands daffy duck is not mean
this is as you think think about it he
doesn't wear pants he doesn't wear pants
puts the shirt on leaves the pants off
that's what it is daffy ducks is out
there
all along he's very sexually aggressive
daffy duck it is true i've never seen
like a bird flying with like a dick
hanging out not like a tea bag by a bird
who doesn't who else doesn't have dicks
they have special dicks it says
they said it's their dicks are like a
corkscrew every dick is special
and they must spiral in the correct
direction now that's not d-shame i'm
clipping that wow look at this
to enter a female a male duck's penis
must be the correct shape like a
corkscrew and it must spiral in the
correct direction if the female has a
vagina that spirals clockwise and the
male's penis goes counterclockwise the
male cannot successfully walk
not compatible
wow that's a good way to get a
relationship but say listen you got you
got counter clock right [ __ ] and i got
clocked right right it's not you it's
literally not you it's just you it's not
your corkscrew it's my vagina that's
what it is
that's hysterical though
it's like opening a bottle of wine when
they have sex that's what it is hyenas
give birth to their large clitorises so
this we're learning stuff today boys
they got a very tough immune system and
they got large uh clitorises uh that
grow to seven inches in length and um
referred to as pseudo penises um phallic
appearance and are used for everything
from sex urination to birth must be very
dirty birth requires females to push
two-pound infants to a birth canal in
the clitoris with a one-inch diameter oh
my the process often leads to clitoral
tears which can be fatal oh high death
rate in first time hyena mothers wow
they ripped their clits open
wow how do we not know this stuff some
sharks carry cannibalistic fetuses in
their womb excuse me
female sand tiger sharks can gestate up
to 12 pups at once but only two will
emerge alive the rest are consumed by
the largest and most aggressive pups
ensuring the fittest possible sharks are
born sand tiger sharks are able to mate
with multiple males at once so this
contest of uh fratricide may be an
evolutionary adaptation to ensure the
dominance of one male's genes over the
other more often than not the remaining
two pups have the same father wow so
they get impregnated twice by multiples
and then the the father that has the
most best sperm
those shark babies eat the other guy's
shark baits which can happen in women
you can get two eggs pregnant at the
same it's very rare but it can happen
right right
i was i've been working on a bit
like where imagine like
female humans gave birth the way
animals do because like there's no
there's no hubbub there's no hospital
visits there's no prep work they get
pregnant and they walk around and then
one day they squat and the baby shoots
out right imagine like i'm just saying
like
we're the only people that don't give
birth that way the only the only animal
that doesn't give birth it's like a
whole song and dance no it's like
imagine you just get pregnant and then
like wherever you are whenever you are
they just like here comes there's no
like not like there's no birthdays it's
just like it's coming out that happens
too people have
you know babies in their lobby in the
cab and the sure they don't make it and
they just have them yeah because in the
animal kingdom it's like you give birth
you better go you need to now nurse that
baby protect the baby go get food it's
like it's just a part of your day right
that just you have to get this baby out
it's literally part of you also think
about the pregnant animal that doesn't
really communicate with people
in the intricacies that we do so
they don't really know except for inside
their own thoughts and stuff like what's
going on with their body like nobody
else it's all instinctual right they
don't even get a registry right
by the way you know what i've noticed
today this is twice now today you've
said the word hubbub you've said hubbub
twice today really so what's going on
where's that coming i don't know i say
hubbub is in my vernac you say hubba and
you say gangbusters a lot too which i
like it's in my neck hubbub how about i
didn't know i said it twice i said hop
up twice i think you might have said it
on a uh earlier in the day but i noticed
as well the second time you said how
about i wanna know what's going on yeah
do you need better health that's fun
though you know to say what's all the
hub bub about what is hubbub
because hubbub for me if you said what
does hubbub mean i would say stub up
what do you mean what does hubble mean i
guess hoopla hop up and hoopla are
synonymous sure what i mean is where
where is the tr where is the word hub
okay hubbub
noise or an uproar confusion or turmoil
got it but what is it short for where
did it come from see where did hub hop
up origin there you go mid 16th century
perhaps of irish origin
1550s hub
was called confused noise of a certain
origin according to irish origin
expression of a version of contempt
i don't know i don't know battle cry i
don't know what that that gives us
anything really
is hub up a real world what do you mean
it's hop up a real world what kind of
piece of [ __ ] are you of course
that's a good one i never heard of that
scroll up another crazy situation that
has gone completely
higgly piglety hicklity piglety what is
that what is his hubbub is a fun rhyming
word for an uproar or brouhaha or
another crazy situation that has gone
completely higglity piglety i like it
what do you like better if you have to
you have to pick one hubbub
hoopla or higglity piglet piglet piglet
he's a new kid on the block right now i
like him bits of paper
higgledy piggledy bits of paper hung
higgly piggly on the furniture and the
walls oh is that like wabi-sabi what's
wabi-sabi um it's kind of like hillary
piglet
what wabi-sabi is like what she wants
it's imperfect i believe is what it
means
wabi-sabi is a japanese term that's
difficult to say without smiling that
describes a profound way of viewing
relationships with oneself other people
and life in general yeah but i think it
also means imperfect i thought
could be wrong what about definition oh
my god
the beauty of age and where but loosely
translated wabi is simplicity whether
elegant or rustic zombie means the
beauty of age and where so if you're
sabi because there's a lot of cultures
that asian ware i think is why i'm where
i'm connecting the imperf and where i
care
because we're a con we're a culture that
really like you know you try to get lip
fillers and dye your hair and all that
but there's other cultures that like
celebrate you getting old like you would
never like once your hair turns great
shout out kane tanaka it's sexy yeah
it's katanaki still with us right yeah
did you see that person that tweeted us
they made a shout out to whoever you are
uh i forget the name but they tweeted us
a picture of the t-shirt they had made
it says kane tanaka versus everybody wow
shout out that person can't versus
everybody um nail it oh we'd love i mean
i'd love to get that shirt it's tanaka
versus everybody
what's up babes want to talk to you
about beam
i don't know if you like me but i
usually sleep very well fall asleep
relatively quickly and never had that
issue but every once in a while like
once every couple of months i have one
of those nights where i cannot fall
asleep and it is the worst feeling in
the absolute world especially when i
gotta get up and i have friends that i
know that suffer from insomnia all the
time so this is a product that you
should be checking out studies show that
sleep affects everything including brain
function mood weight loss overall health
and more and a full eight hours with no
interruptions is necessary for quality
sleep okay luckily for those of us who
need help falling asleep beams dream
powder is here to give you the best
sleep of your entire life what is dream
powder it's a comforting sleep-promoting
hot cup of cocoa that you can mix for
yourself every night i got this bean
cocoa in the mail and i used it about a
week and a half ago and then i used it
the next night the next night and the
next night first of all
i'll start with a taste because it
tastes absolutely delicious just get
some really hot water and uh i literally
was sipping on it i'm like this is so
comforting it really was delicious and
then i slept like a mofo the whole night
i kept using it i now
as soon as this bag is out i'm getting
another bag this is how much i like this
stuff i don't always try every single
thing that we have advertised for but
this stuff i like and there's no thc
that's important if you guys don't know
the difference it is cbd but it's triple
lab tested no added sugar or artificial
sweeteners it's just the mixed dream
powder with hot water or warm milk which
i haven't tried and i'm gonna and end
your night with a warm cup of good stuff
that'll be sure to help you get
incredible sleep
everyone needs this if you subscribe now
you get 35 off your first month of dream
plus get a free mug and frother which i
got and it's pretty cool i make it with
the frother head to beam organics dot
com slash hey babe that's b e a m
organics dot com slash h h-e-y-b-a-b for
35 off your first month of your dream
subscription plus you can pause or
cancel any time all right babes you know
we love babble over here and uh if you
haven't heard us talk about babel it's a
learning uh language app uh you know and
learning a language can feel
intimidating okay um
you know i don't know people take online
classes i don't know in class but babel
is the number one selling language
learning app the whole process has been
reworked it's super fun fast and easy
whether you want to learn a new language
for an upcoming trip a new hobby or just
brush up on what you used to know babel
teaches bite-sized language lessons for
real-world use you could use it on the
go which is my favorite part they have
15 minute lessons so you can learn when
you have a moment if you're on a commute
for the day or you're eating your lunch
or whatever just before bed uh other
language apps use ai for the lesson
plans the reason babel stands apart is
it was created by over a hundred
language experts
and their teaching methods have been
scientifically proven to be effective 14
languages all the hits are in there
great speech recognition technology
helps you improve your enunciation which
i think makes a big difference too
and uh you can do live classes stories
games videos podcasts really awesome the
lessons are really awesome 20-day
money-back guarantee right now when you
purchase three-month babble subscription
you'll get three months additional for
free that's six months for the price of
three
if you go to babel.com and use promo
code hey babe that's
b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com code hey-bay babble
language for life i um
yeah c c c
well v j whale vagina
sorry sorry because sometimes when i'm
on my duck
it's very hard to concentrate when i'm
running on duncan i'm not running on
anything right now i'm not running on
anything i know you've been up for three
hours i haven't had one call i didn't
have any i haven't i i haven't had any
beverage yet so you've been up for three
to four hours you haven't poured
anything into your body i had that
110 calorie granola bar what's going on
with you don't have the shakes what's
going on no nothing i just we had to
start right away and yeah i didn't have
time to eat you know what i want for
lunch today tacos
i almost had him last night for dinner
but i didn't
homemade big story big story what
happened no i was out i was at a
restaurant and i ended up getting oh you
know what i have downstairs the other
half of my sandwich i got a
short rib melt
yummy yummy in my tummy yeah from z1
where's z1 uh it's a great diner kind of
bar and grill type place richmond as i
do know where z1 is big place right yeah
you went there out for dinner last night
yeah my my dad goes uh sometimes and so
i met him and we had we had dinner
my dad and my cousin he won now you had
you had a melt and then did you have i
started with a beef barley soup cup wow
yeah
a cup and i had a half the tuna milk uh
the short red melt i brought it home how
do you only eat half a sandwich i also
had one uh fresh baked chocolate chip
cookie that the waitress made
the waitress made it yeah really did she
go rogue or is that part of the menu now
she she just brings him in for the her
good customers she bakes you're one of
the good customers my dad your dad's a
good guy yeah he lives close to there is
that why he's a good customer no he
lives in another state he lives in
jersey right yeah yeah no he used to go
there all the time before he left so now
he comes like once a week to hang that
nice just he hangs out at z1 oh look he
meets all of his friends i think i went
to z1 once i think i had had a lovely
affair with a woman um on staten island
and then you're
i want to say unprotected sex and then
went to
this is five
no five to eight years ago nine years
ago we don't protect sex i slept over a
house on the floor if i don't if i if i
remember correctly i slept on her
carpeted floor because she didn't think
that it was right that i slept in her
bed even though we had unprotected sex
in the backseat of her car i want to say
we then went so we had a some type of
there's some type of like
church on staten island that has like
all like outside of it on the front law
in the backyard all pictures of all
statues of mary and saints yeah that's
on victory boulevard yeah we went there
to pray yeah i believe that goes there
to pray all the time i think we went
there i guess to pray the sin away yeah
and then we went to z1 you probably were
hanging around around my dad that day i
probably your dad might have been the
woman i had an affair with
yeah he does i have a question would you
guys ever have both your dads on the
show yes yes oh hell yeah my dad would
be honest i would like to have your dad
on the show and see how many apple cider
vinegar shots he can take in and out
actually so funny my dad last night he
says to me because uh i had that show in
atlantic city coming up december 11th
saturday at the borgata events center
tickets are on sale now several kind of
comic.com uh december 11. so he told me
last night because they're they're all
coming they haven't never seen me do
stand-up wow your father has never no
they saw me one time i played the joy
theater after the cruise docked what's
your voice my voice was completely gone
and i only did 25 minutes and i i
literally i was talking like this and i
didn't want to give up the show i told
you that time right remember you told me
when yamaneika did a prayer
yeah if you have any can help me uh and
uh yeah so my dad goes hey hey
when are you gonna put me in your act
wow yeah cause i have jokes about my mom
but i don't have anything about my dad i
told myself i have jokes about my dad
nothing about my mom it's funny right
wow so i told him last night i said you
know what dad it's december 11th i'll
put some thought into it wow and i'm
going to be there i'll film uh his
reaction here yes that's are they going
to let you into the morgana to film yeah
yeah okay
yeah pimpy's coming with me to boston
the day before december 10th december
and uh nac those will be two nice shows
you got a nice night maybe hey you know
what maybe i'll maybe i'll come along
too i'll be around it we'll see that'd
be great so i wanted to come see you at
the beacon actually on feb 5.
so then i got uh a weekend booked and
i'm like i'm supposed to be in tulsa
but then then on top of the weekend i
gotta get right to a wedding of a good a
pretty good friend of mine in la so now
i don't know what to do it's a triple
tug of war between the beacon the
wedding
and going on the road you must get
endless wedding invites i get a lot of
wedding invites but it's only because i
keep a big social circle this is a big
you're going to go february 5th the
options are see me at the beacon theater
in new york city
go to a close friend's wedding or be in
tulsa oklahoma yeah we put up a poll
i'll i'll let the hay babes decide
let's do it oh okay because on this on
february 5th do i go to a wedding
in la of a good friend
uh do i go to chris's one of my best
friends show at the beacon
that's
huge theater new york or do i go on the
road and make money for myself and my
family in tulsa oklahoma tulsa yeah and
the night before is like oklahoma it's
double oklahomes oklahoma back i've
never been stepped foot inside the state
of oklahoma no really never in my life
great musical
great musical uh i've been there a bunch
i've been to the oklahoma state fair as
a matter of fact which has got to be
that is the fair right yes the iowa
state fair
i mean this thing was
gangbusters gang bust no they think this
thing had like
tens and tens of thousands of people
it's pretty dope
i would imagine like nobody's busy wow
i actually got a wallet made did i show
you my uh my black leather wallet that
has inscribed on it in like laser
etching fat [ __ ] oh yes
you got it there i got it there
there was a boot and it was like a like
an 85 year old grey-haired woman and she
had all leather goods from bags to belts
to wallets and they did engraving for
free if you bought the wallet and i was
like oh man i got to get this on the
wall i didn't have to tell the woman i
might have told you the story and i just
goes for the show you just did this for
you for myself
so i said to her hey do you engrave
anything on those wallets she goes yeah
she was like old gruff woman and i said
okay cause what i want to put on there
is a little bit questionable but it's a
it's a nickname that my friends call me
i just made it because i didn't want her
to feel like like i was saying that to
her and like whoa take it easy so i i
softened it i said so my friends call me
this and she goes what do you want to
put on the wall and i go
can you put fat [ __ ] on the wallet she
goes it'll be ready in five
[Laughter]
could not
care
care
year
wow dude yeah dude i have never stepped
foot in oklahoma like tulsa oklahoma
city nice places yeah yeah i mean i
don't remember them too much because
i've only been there a few times
two years on tour right but that fair
was dope oklahoma baby yeah well
february 5th he's in a predicament what
should he do email the podcast hey
baypodcastgmail.com
or if pim tweets out a poll do that but
what you do a drones and dopholis breaks
off inside a queen's b vagina so when
you're having b sex so that's like when
when someone says i'll break her off a
piece that's what it is they're
literally doing that this b's like i'll
break you off so i'm gonna break you off
a piece of this endophilus
[Laughter]
[Music]
to inject sperm into the queen's vagina
an action that causes the endophylus to
detach and the drones to die soon
thereafter wow oh yeah that's like the
uh what's his name the praying mantis
right he cro the woman
murders him after she bangs i think she
rips his head off yeah you got a a real
uh what was that lady who killed the guy
ever
no not lorraine and bobby the
judy arrance yeah anthony yeah no who's
chasing there was the kid right yeah
yeah jody jody
she's like a praying mantis she's a
praying mantis she killed the guy right
kill the guy yeah
blue whales have large vaginas
okay yeah we that's the one we knew yeah
they got the biggest vaginas 10 feet
long vagina and weigh anywhere from 300
to 990 pounds depending on its overall
size that is a big talk about a fat [ __ ]
nailed it that's the joke
elephant pregnancies last nearly two
years i mean talk wowzers wow 22 months
on not if they literally we've been
doing this podcast for a year they're
halfway through their production
how nuts is that wow you'd be halfway
through wow
and you're carrying the baby that long
geez i delivered a cow
yes i fell out almost our size fully
like it was nearly our size as a baby
born newborn i mean forget about i mean
how big is an elephant dolphins have
vaginas designed to thwart shooters
they're like duck vaginas they're like
oh i heard that about them too and don't
dolphins rape allegedly i mean that's i
mean obviously ducks
yeah possums are only pregnant for 12
days that's a quickie that is
insanity i bet women out there would
love to have that that is insane so
another possum forms within a fully
formed possum from in conception to to
to to to to to fully formed is 12 days
12 days it's one of the shortest
pregnancies in the animal problem with a
newborn emerging less than two weeks
after insemination
how is that even feasible i dude i don't
know possums are terrifying to me though
they're so scary disgusting i've seen
people who have them as pets
dude seeing a possum in the middle of
the night is legitimately terrifying
they're like rats right they're wrapped
but they're huge oh they're so
disgusting shout out possums a six foot
drop severs of babies giraffes and
biblical cord oh because giraffes have
the highest vaginas in the world
umbilical yeah um so the umbilic right
the umbilical yeah the abil i said being
biblical yeah and biblical i'm reading
my yeah uh yeah it's it's in a biblical
it's in in biblical proportions right
right the storm wasn't biblical before
correct yeah
so uh yeah but i wonder if why there are
there like billions of possums then
i don't imagine like oh you're possibly
having a relationship with another
possum and you're like i gave birth
yesterday
yeah
when's the last time you slept with
someone 12 days ago 12 days ago yeah
look at these kids look at these kids
they're all grown up don't forget i was
at the uh i think san diego zoo with
nate bargati and the lady said they're
opossums never call them possums yeah
which i thought it was silent
is it a possibility you know what ladies
and gentlemen why don't you why don't
you just shut your mouth yeah and just
open up the cages please um it's zagat
yeah same lady you know what dummy now
i'm not going to the san diego zoo
um uh a hundred hundred different
species of opossum
wow it's called the
dai de la feidi family of marsupials is
native to the new world the vagina
virginia opossum shout out marshall
appeals
the fun
name i thought if you said hey have you
ever encountered my sweeping life so
what if i live in australia right i've
seen a possum last night yeah dead on
the side of the road soups are all
around us we'd even know it that's more
soup and what makes a marsupial and they
have their
young in pockets they put them in little
pouches more soupies oh koalas in the
soup
a mammal of an order whose members are
born incompletely developed and are
typically carried and suckled in a pouch
on the mon the mother's cats with the
possum then they're not they born in 12
days but they fully ain't even done yet
okay
okay they ain't baked yet no yeah
including possums who mainly live in
america
this potty wadi is sponsored by
betterhelp this podcast
in case you guys don't know what that
means it's sponsored better help that's
help not health it's help okay uh is
there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
uh i think that every single one of us
if you're a human being uh says that
that is happening to them uh you know
that we shout out better help all the
time on this podcast they've been with
us a while and you know the deal if you
listen but i'm gonna repeat it for you a
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating with them in under 48
hours uh it's professional counseling
done securely online that's what this is
it's not self-help or a crisis line uh
because you do it online you have a
range of experts that span many areas so
you can speak to someone who has
expertise in something that you wouldn't
normally get locally okay and it's
available worldwide so to all our
listeners in ghana
go
uh you can log into your account anytime
send message to your counselor anytime
they get
timely thoughtful responses back to you
um you could schedule weekly video phone
sessions whatever you want okay um go to
the website if you want to check it out
if you're hesitant go to the website
read their reviews
uh because there are over a million
people that have taken charge of their
mental health using better help in fact
so many people have been using it that
they recruited new counselors in every
state special offer for our hey babe
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
hey babe that's again help b e t t e r h
e l p dot com slash hey babe
abe yes stan socks i am so happy about
this we actually wear these all the time
i'm a user for years and years for use
the best pair of socks i ever had ever
in my life were socks made by stance
yeah larry johnson grandmama stan socks
yeah charlotte hornets best socks most
comfortable and most design friendly
sizes i got a david bowie stance i got a
steelers stance i got a biggie stance
one of my most comfortable socks i got
so many pairs of stance socks and
they're the only ones like the no ankle
ones the low ones they're the only ones
i wear i bought like nine pairs oh stan
socks they're so comfortable i always i
like that little stitch that lit their
little symbol it's always right there
always feels good they got wu-tang socks
disney socks nba socks premium line of
socks apparel and more always come
correct with colorful constructions
innovative materials and choice fits
that are built to last throwing an
all-star curation of a-list
collaborators and those lucky recipients
on your holiday nice list that's
by the way what's a more perfect gift
than some sweet stand socks
well you know when you open up socks
like
underwear that your parents or your
grandmother get you because you need to
yeah it's a utility gift it always comes
every year in the stockings if it's a
stance sock all of a sudden now we're
playing ball you know what you know what
i didn't have coal how about this my
feet never stink and stand socks is that
true it's a stinkless foot wow
no the thing about i like it is that
they are comfortable and they are it's
cool and not a lot of people can do that
people try people try yeah but you can't
do it stan socks you can get your own
stance socks if you go to
stance.com that's
s-t-a-n-c-e-dot-com pick out some styles
you think your family and friends may
like go punk go poet whatever you want
to do enjoy the color and comfort of a
life less ordinary with sans
well possums are native to america
possums are hideous
[Laughter]
are they the least animal the ugliest
animal yeah i would say a possum
possum is the ugliest animal also i mean
bats are disgusting
look at this blob fish
oh my god it looks like a a human
sperm he looks like somebody's social
studies teacher
that looks like just an old guy who
melted yeah disgusting
that is weird
oh god what is that what is that with
the teeth naked
naked
i mean you think they look at us and
like yikes
oh my what is that the hell is that
what's this popular with the ladies
elephant
an elephant an elephant seal i didn't
even know there was an elephant never
heard of it elephant seals wow that must
be a big big big thing
oh my god who's that carl molden
google carl molden so you know what i'm
talking about please
carl molden
yes his favorite tray he's he's got a
big nose
he's an old actor
[Laughter]
i've seen this guy before his nose his
nose
am i right noah got that reference that
was like just now that was like wendy
williams for me yeah
wendy williams oh wow that thing looks
cute that thing looks psychotic it does
if i like like walked into a room and i
think was this staring at me i would i
would kill myself
i mean i don't know what the hell that
looks like that literally looks like the
demogorgon from uh
from stranger things that is oh my god
what is that
the acid what's that i can't see that
baby
salamander that regenerates oh that's up
there okay baby
oh my god that looks demonic it looks
good that's not bad whatever what is
that looks like a little dinosaur that's
a salamander
what the [ __ ] oh is that pumbaa warthog
that's a warthog that's what a warthog
looks like kuna matata baby i thought
warthogs look like pigs
that is tusks yeah that'll kill you look
at this thing i mean it's just a fish
with two big eyeballs
not bad oh this one makes delicious
little that that doesn't look terrible
yeah what's that a bird a puffy bird
just a puffy fat [ __ ] bird have you guys
ever had a wild animal stuck in your
house no have you i have squirrels
squirrels
yeah
dude you know squirrels in the wall you
know what i i have squirrel i don't have
squirrels but i do have a huge problem i
have a beehive on the outside of my
house the bees one by one are starting
to get into the house you got it you
gotta you gotta i know it's paying for
the invite but you gotta get someone to
come and at least take it away well we
had we hired someone i forgot what the
company was called we hired them to come
take care of the problem the guy showed
up i swear to god in a t-shirt and
shorts got up on the ladder put the
shirt over his face like this i swear to
god sprayed the thing got stung
[Laughter]
you can ask jasmine this and then left
and sent me a bill for three hundred
dollars no yeah no did you pay it no you
call him on the phone i'm not paying him
we should call them on the phone here
have that air air that out right on the
pod dude he'll say that tell him i want
to i want to see this unfolds yeah
because because because he
he sprayed from mosquitoes which he told
us may or may not work and then
literally i said that's the beehive
right there and he i couldn't believe
what he was doing we were like don't you
have to put a suit on anything like that
and he sprayed it and got attacked and
got hit by a bee and left
was he a mosquito guy in a b world he
was a mosquito guy in the boat then my
pool guy like he was like i could try to
get rid of the bees well yeah yeah or
was he a
he he no no they usually have a hat he
you know no no he wasn't i don't think
he was a keeper i don't think he was a
big kid okay
he and then my pool guy shout out my
pool guy i mean nicest guy in the world
i sent him a check i think to close the
pool was whatever 300 310 dollars and 67
cents he calls me goes hey what's up
what's going on he goes um made a little
mistake here he goes sometimes my
handwriting is not legible he goes it's
actually 310.27
you overpaid me by 40 cents how can i
get that to you i swear to god and i was
like that's a keeper i said you can keep
speaking of keepers yes he's a keeper
then his assistant i saw him in the
staten island mall with i'm not talking
i'm not like bandages from his legs up
to the bottom of his belly but i was
walking around with jasmine i said what
are you what's going on you okay that
corner filter no he go no yeah no he
says uh he he says um i was uh i said
did i do outside work like not pool
related and i was putting in a fire pit
and blew up on me he goes so yeah half
my body sec third degree burns whole way
down he goes oh my god he goes it's a
game change he goes but i'll be ready
for your pool next season oh my gosh
dude but he was just walking through
macy's with with a full i mean i was
like why are you even out
remissing in pain every step no way
every time he took a step he was like
it must have been a good sale yeah had
to be bring him out of the house had to
be could still get you out of the house
third degree burns and all my favorite
was watching the landscapers murder your
halloween decorations oh my god how
about this landscapers yesterday
literally come outside they're done you
know either leaves blonde whatever
you've done all my halloween decorations
ripped off strings ripped off huge piles
of dirt like holes in my front lawn
let's say that i don't know no i called
them i called him i said hey buddy how
you doing i said
you know you guys were just you and your
men were just here all my halloween
decorations are broken and there's
there's holes in the floor he's like
i'll be back in five minutes
what'd he do came right back in five
minutes until the water went back up and
put and covered up the holes he was like
he was trying to get away with something
i guess i mean he was like oh so he came
back and decorated your house yeah he
put the halloween decorations back up
that's hysterical he's the one who
ripped him down wow yeah and the garbage
men haven't picked up the garbage have
the garbagemen come here
to my home yeah what do you mean have
they come the garbage men have not
picked up the garbage in three weeks oh
you you're you might be are you are you
in a um a community do you pay for
private service are you going oh no i
got dsny baby no garbage well you don't
know because you just dropped your
garbage off at the building i drop it in
a chute and it drops down and i never
said you're not dealing with it's one of
the amenities the super is dealing with
it i'm dealing with
piles of garbage in front of all our
homes because the garbage men are in a
slow down they refuse to pick up the
garbage you got a three one one that
nobody they probably get they don't care
it's city wide so it's city wine wow
someone making toast i smell toast i
thought i was having one i want toast i
know you better you better hope that
it's toasty hope there's extra toast
can i have a tuna sandwich on like like
tuna like mayonnaise
celery in it
no answer
she's looking at me like i'm insane he
said jojo rosa no no it's
how much time do we have how much
minutes are we into we were saying
you're making toast maybe six minutes
you making toast no
you're not making toast no eggs
and toast english muff
see where i gotta go to arrive at the
destination i got to make 10 turns
instead of going straight
technically listen i do
uh well i always agree with you and i
still do agree with you
technically an english muff
is not toast is it toasted
yes but if you said to me yeah give me a
piece of toast and you gave me an
english muff i would say i'm going to
take this because i love it
but this isn't this isn't toast toast
has to be sliced bread english muff
is not sliced bread that's a good that's
like i don't know if most people would
consider english muffins toast i don't
know if i i'd say this i'd be within my
rights to say i ordered toast you gave
me an english muffin send it back i'd be
within my right say that if you did do
that though it'd be a little bit like
you're a tough guy to get along with
because it's all one and the same but
technically
it's an english muff
i got you
i'm gonna look it up right now i'm gonna
i'm sitting in the aisle on this flight
tomorrow
that was all that was left i think i'm
sitting in the aisle are you really oh
no i'm sitting in the one row one seater
i'm gonna i'm gonna put up a pole why
are you anti-aisle
me yeah no he never even has to pee nah
you pee once a week i don't pee yeah i
poo once a week i do once every two days
i i do i i don't like dial because uh
everybody walks past you and nails into
you and then there's nothing to lean on
to fall asleep and then inevitably if
you do fall asleep and someone's gonna
hit into your arm right away they hit
the you know with the cart they're
reaching over to give the food to the
other person i like to not be seen hurt
i go in i took away a full sleep i lean
against the window i like to control the
window you like to control the window
window let yourself fall asleep on a
short flight i feel like no i will let
myself fall asleep any time i can on a
flight yeah yeah see i i i need if i
didn't have to pee i would always sit
window the reason i need aisles because
i constantly have to pee
i
it's crazy how much we balance each
other he pees once every two days and i
pee once every two minutes
i peed i'm not lying dude an average day
of pee-pee for me is 15 a day i've
watched yeah and people are like oh it's
because you're diabetes i was like have
i been diabetic since i'm seven
we'll find out probably i'm putting up
this poll for us okay you ask for toast
someone brings you a toasted english
muffin
does this
derosa's going to be so mad at this pole
okay
are you
happy with this
or do you consider
this
sound sock today looks like a bandage
it's cute right looks like your foot's
bandaged up like in a fun cast yeah
you're right yeah but it's a nice sock
these are specialty socks for cooks
what yeah
i just i like to i like to style them so
i bought what do you mean a specialty
sock for what is that the pan what does
the chef need extra padding underneath
on this god forbid you get burning hot
water on you no i just just for
for comfort like for padding because
you're always standing yeah but it's i
was gonna say you're not cooking with
socks on
no no like if i'm a chef these are the
socks i'm wearing
under my shoes because it's but you
don't have to be a chef you could be you
could be a flight attendant and wear
those socks absolutely any job i bought
it from a company that also sells
specializing in like aprons and cookware
and things like that right but okay but
i'm just saying like it has nothing to
do with like
you know hot water and stuff it's just
they're standing on their feet a lot so
they want a comfortable sock
yes correct 100 so if we were doing this
podcast standing up we could wear those
socks
yeah
are they is is every sock one size fits
all or do some do do they have some
socks like small medium large
you ever seen a sock that has a size
yeah really yeah and but it's always
like size six to twelve and it's like
all right well yeah why are we doing
this yeah yeah it's too big
uh i'm going to put this pole up and
we're going to see what people think
is a toasted english muffin toast how
about this i got lululemon socks on
you know oh you always want with lemon
socks
are they good
you know honestly
they've they feel good
would you i've been would you recommend
can we open this on this episode yeah
look at this look at this so i got
so let this like a few months ago it was
the mtv tv movie genuinely i'm not lying
20 pounds yeah there was a movie and tv
awards and
practical jokers won best unscripted
comedy right hey babe why not yeah
so uh it was like months ago and i got
this in the mail yesterday so each guy
got one yeah this this is the award i
mean the box itself is amazing yeah
isn't that crazy it's i can't believe it
i thought it was gonna be a piece of
[ __ ] no like lightning heavy yeah i'll
open up this side
oh
let's see
what oh wow look at that i've i've seen
these on tv
go ahead pull one out can i get it
oh
can we get it out
can we break this thing right now
look at that wow
look at that guys unscripted movie ntv
mtv
music award it's actually metal i
thought it was gonna be like
really not heavy wait a minute sal can
we can we get a victory speech i mean by
the way it says presented i wasn't there
the guys were there they accepted the
award and did a speech right it says
your name presented the sound volcano
best comedy game show on practical
jokers game show oh comedy slash game
show that's what said comedy slash game
show yeah so i forget who we were up
against i think it was like
i i don't know who it was but after all
these years this is the first time
you've ever won this yeah real first
time we've ever nominated really yeah
because i don't think in the priors i
don't know in prior they were do they
always nominate people not on the
network i don't know yeah i don't know
either there you go babe wow thank you
so much congratulations
i appreciate it come see me on tour
avocadocomedy.com
are you gonna are you gonna put it up
somewhere or is this just gonna be like
you put it in put it on i guess i could
put it on the moon
is this award to you compared to other
awards
let's just be honest iran hey babe
i i this is
it's a cool thing to have i really like
think it's a cool like
it's a nice honor and it's a cool thing
to have but it means it's zero to me
ziggy yeah like i don't want to look
anyone i'm not looking to give horse in
the mouth i really appreciate having
this right but i don't i don't really
buy into award shows in general not just
mtv right yeah it's just it's a big hand
job thing kind of but this i think this
also might have had there was an element
of fan voting so if that's the truth
i believe because our fans are the
greatest seems like this is the only
award you guys have won is that right i
don't know only it says the only one
time you've won an award in practice or
best comedy slash game show at the mtv
movie and tv awards there it is 20 21.
we did which practical joker died that's
nice
is official oh is this a bit
what
an apparent home invasion robbery and
silver like in 2013. wow it looks good
for a dead guy gado was shot during a
home invasion yeah i mean i spoke to him
last night yeah there you go
we wanna i wanna bet the best new
podcast when we did what to say you
that's up there see that 2013. oh is
that like a webby yeah i guess it was
from the stitch from stitcher that was
like okay uh and one time we won what is
going on i don't know somebody must have
somebody must be messing with the
practical jokers said it ended seven
years ago um we did win like a pole star
thing did you ever see that no pole star
is like the company that ranks
touring
for musicians and comedians and stuff
like that so if you sell like a certain
amount of tickets or something like that
you win an award they get an award
you're getting no it's not like a
ceremony we got a big plaque and a frame
and everything sent to us and uh and
then we got on the cover of the pole
star magazine which is industry magazine
as i'm told it was a big deal okay but
they ranked the 20 top touring comedians
um and we were 10. amazing yeah there's
a big drop off like not a big driver but
like one and two then there's a little
bit of a drop one and two with sebastian
and seinfeld and they were like neck and
neck yeah yeah they were neck and neck
but when it when it came out like this
was like a couple years ago sebastian
probably now has has probably demolished
that right because when it came out it
said he made 22 million touring that
year that's a long time jerry it was 20
million interesting yeah interesting
well
the fans want to send in awards for
chris yeah listen
if if yeah if anybody would like to send
in an award for me just to make me feel
you're always at those award shows were
you no i went one year and no i didn't
win an award and i took i got a picture
with lady gaga though
really yeah that's cool you would be a
great host for the mtv awards hey listen
you'd be a great host and tv people if
you're if you're watching and i know
that you are yeah yeah i'll be the host
i really do believe that i think you
would you would be you were killing that
in that scenario i believe i'd be a good
host i don't believe i'd be better than
tom brady because he won the super bowl
in tampa bay god bless him 43 years old
oldest guy in the nfl oldest guy
you want to flip side to that young guy
in the nfl patrick mahomes yeah shout
out to him in his institution over there
what happens man cancer chief's not
playing well this year tom brady threw a
600 pass a 600 touchdown what can you do
shout out tom brady shout out to
everybody so maybe or maybe hey babe
hosts the mtv awards why don't we do
that put that out put out put that out
into the world
if you want to see us co-headlining
together december 26th to the 31st go to
salvocanocomedy.com or chrisdcomedy.com
texas st louis uh columbus ohio and the
new year's eve cincinnati ohio go get
the tickets hashtag bay fest 2021
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey
guys come see me at the west palm beach
improv december 4th and 5th come see me
at the chevy year theater in boston on
december 10th i'm really looking forward
to that it's almost sold out so get
tickets and then also almost sold out my
first time at the borgata in atlantic
city saturday december 11th all tickets
on sale at savilecanocomedy.com
brian quinn will be at the show at the
borgata he just told me that and
there'll be other surprises hope to see
you there my dad will be there too whoa
i wish i could go but i can't because
december 2nd to the 4th i'll be in
phoenix arizona december 17th and 18th
i'll be at west palm beach in florida uh
then december 26th to the 31st sal and i
will be together in texas
missouri and ohio january 29th i'll be
at the borgana february 5th beacon new
york city march 25th to win las vegas
christy comedy.com for all the new dates
that are up there thank you man we love
you